une salve de remerciements adressés au
président français
merci beaucoup emmanuel macron érigé en
défenseur des droits sociaux africains
et plus particulièrement le droit à la
vaccination
aucun un sommet sur le financement des
économies africaines
le chef d'état français alerté par son
homologue sénégalais sur le comportement
parfois individualiste adoptée par les
grandes nations du monde
en temps de crise sanitaire nous avons
une responsabilité commune et que
vacciner sa population pour les pays
industrialisés ne leur garantit
absolument pas la sécurité sanitaire
si nous continuons la tendance actuelle
au les africains selon à 2% 3 % de
vacciner il se développera sur le
continent africain
bavaria extrêmement résistant un message
envoyé depuis paris et à destination
notamment du continent européen
charles michel président du conseil
européen d'ailleurs présents tout comme
les représentants des principales
organisations financières
internationales
après donc les états unis et à la
demande incessante de l'inde et de
l'afrique du sud
emmanuel macron approuvent à demi mot
une levée des brevets sur les vaccins
appuyant davantage sur l'importance des
transferts de technologie et appelle à
augmenter les productions de dos il ya
un an nous avons lancé l'initiative
kovacs objectif de vacciner 20% de la
population
l'union africaine a lancé l'initiative
avat pour monter à 30%
nous devons viser un objectif de 40% de
la population vaccinée
c'est faisable et c'est faisable en 21
un projet estimé à 50 milliards de
dollars pour produire des vaccins en
afrique pour l'afrique
le fonds monétaire international est
sollicité de grandes promesses mais
surtout un travail de dédiabolisation
auto du vaccin est préconisée par les
grands chefs d'état africains il n'y a
pas assez de de mobilisation de leur
côté là de la part de nos populations
c'est une certaine inquiétude qui est dû
au fait à mon sens que le vaccin vient
d'ailleurs
voilà pourquoi il est nécessaire de
viser la production de vaccins en
afrique le président de la rdc se
désolant d'avoir reçu plus d'un million
cinq cent mille 2 et n'avoir pu vacciner
que dix mille personnes pour la plupart
des expatriés une crise sanitaire
doublette une crise économique
la communauté internationale a
l'ambition de mobiliser 100 milliards de
dollars pour aider le continent africain
à se relever de la pandémie mais aussi
lutter contre le terrorisme et
discussions doivent continuer en ce sens
au sommet des g7 et g20 en juin et
octobre prochain c'est intéressant dans
le monde
non mais